uh but we are very proud of the work of
our chairman
of the intelligence committee uh our we
take this to be a very sad time for the
american people
for our country impeaching a president
or
having the investigation to feature
president is not
anything to be
joyful about i don't know that anybody's
joyful but it is a sad
time and as you've heard me say over and
over again
in the dark days of the revolution
thomas payne said
the times have found us we think the
times have found us now
not that we place ourselves in a
category of greatness
of our founders but we do place
ourselves in a time of urgency
on the threat to the constitution a
system of checks and balances
that is being made it is
they fought for our independence they
declared independence
they fought and won they established
a democracy thank god they made the
constitution amendable so it could
always
ever be expanding freedom and we see the
actions of this president
being an assault on the constitution uh
once we had his even admission to that
we had no choice but to go forward
it's hard we want to weigh the equities
we want to be
fair as we go forward and are
we couldn't be better served than by the
leadership of our chairman of the
intelligence committee adam schiff and
my honor to present him to you now
thank you madam speaker and uh thank you
for leading
the entire house of representatives
through this uh very uh
fraught time uh in the history of the
congress indeed the history of the
country
i also want to express my own condolence
once again
to the family of jamal khashoggi
who bravely sought to advocate
for free expression in saudi arabia and
it cost him his life
we are deeply in his debt and we are
determined to
bring about justice for those who are
responsible for that
heinous murder uh it's also an
appropriate time to recognize the danger
facing journalists
all over the world um
in terms of the issues that we've been
focused on this week i want to give you
a brief update
um of what has transpired
really just within the last week last
thursday the intelligence committee held
an open hearing with the acting director
of national intelligence
the following day chairman engel issued
a subpoena to the state department in
close
consultation with myself and chairman
cummings
we are deeply concerned about secretary
pompeo's effort now to
potentially interfere with witnesses who
whose testimony is
needed before our committee many of whom
are mentioned in the whistleblower
complaint
and we want to make it abundantly clear
that any effort
by the secretary by the president or
anyone else
to interfere with the congress's ability
to
call before it relevant witnesses will
be considered as evidence of obstruction
of the lawful functions of congress
and more than that will allow a an
adverse inference to be drawn as to the
underlying facts
uh that if they are going to prevent
witnesses from coming forward
to testify on the allegations in the
whistleblower complaint
that will create an adverse
inference that those allegations are in
fact correct
on monday i issued a
subpoena to rudy giuliani again in
consultation with chairman cummings and
engel
we expect mr giuliani to
comply with the legal process we are
using
uh he is obviously a key figure in all
of this by his own admission as well as
by the allegations
in the whistleblower complaint uh today
and just within the last hour
a half hour chairman cummings um
noticed a subpoena that will go out
later
uh in this week or next week after the
notice period has expired
that that committee intends to subpoena
documents
that the white house has been
withholding from congress
we are obviously coordinating very
closely with chairman cummings on that
on thursday ambassador volcker is
scheduled to appear before our committee
uh and on friday inspector general the
inspector general of the ic mr atkinson
will
appear before the committee and testify
as well uh the last time
that the inspector general testified we
did not have the complaint we now do
and we certainly intend to asked the
director
about the efforts that were made to
corroborate
that complaint which we now know the
inspector general found
both credible and urgent next week we
have also scheduled a deposition or
interview with the
former u.s ambassador ivanovic to
ukraine
and we are in discussion with other
state department witnesses to secure
their depositions
so we've been very busy as you can tell
this week we're going to be very busy
again next week
we are proceeding deliberately uh but at
the same time
we feel a real sense of urgency here
uh that this work needs to get done and
it needs to get done in a responsible
period of time
thank you